good morning Hank it's Tuesday greetings
from the floor of a hotel room it's
September 25th which means that you're
booked an absolutely remarkable thing is
out in the world it's out of lovely
reception so far people have been
sending me updates as they read it and
pictures of themselves reading it and
also the reviews are great like The
Associated Press just called it a
thrilling journey that takes a hard look
at the power of Fame it really is a
at the power of Fame and tonight we get
to celebrate the book here in New York
City at the Town Hall one of my favorite
places in the world and then we go on
tour and I am just so happy that last
night I started crying for no reason
except for gratitude but Hank in
addition to this being a very exciting
time I would imagine it's also a
somewhat stressful time because this
thing that you have been working on for
more than five years is now being read
by lots of people and that's exciting
but also scary and Hank when I feel like
that I find comfort and joy in one
extremely specific place that I would
like to share with you today I am
referring of course to the boot to big
subreddit you know boot to big Hank
roses are red sugar is sweet his boot
too big for his gosh darn feet lightly
edited because my kids watch
vlogbrothers now I don't know what it is
about this joke construction that I find
completely irresistible but like roses
are red the zoo has elephants please
urinate with precision and elegance
there must be something about the meter
of roses are red violets are blue sugar
is sweet and so are you that just like
calm some reptilian part of my brain
even though the poem itself is terrible
and for the record violets are usually
violet but when you take the same meter
and expand it to other worlds I just
find it inexpressibly delightful like
violets are indigo mockumentaries are
silly on this day nine years ago I
dropped the pot of chili roses are red
you can't sink the Titanic
if Waffle House closes it's time to
panic here's one of my very favorite
ones roses are red I'm not a hero gasps
I can't do it
Oh roses are red I'm not a hero gas leak
at cybergoth rave kills zero also it's
just a reminder of how lovely the world
can be if you pay extremely close
attention like roses are red Jordan
could dunk we know he can swim but can
Richard funk roses are red blasphemy is
unholy I mean nobody wants to admit they
ate nine cans of ravioli roses are red
I'm a trendsetter camouflage pants are
get
better and better there are also
wordless boot to bigs and as you know
Hank I'm not much for buns but I'm gonna
give you one because I know that you
love a dad joke
best dad jokes in town this puns for you
fam if you're happy and you know it
clamp your hams okay just three more
then I'll get serious again roses are
red Hakuna Matata
life is a party and on the pinata roses
are red violets are blue stop killing
mountains to make Mountain Dew and
lastly roses are red Mercury's and
thermometers invincible mousse next five
kilometers I hope that brought you some
joy Hank it certainly made me happy so
there's a moment at the end of the movie
back to the future when George McFly
opens a box to find finished copies of
his book a match made in space and as a
kid I often dreamt of that moment
getting to see my own story in the world
Hank you've been working on this book
for more than five years but I know
you've been dreaming of this moment for
much much longer than that so
congratulations I am so excited for you
and for everyone to read an absolutely
remarkable thing nerdfighteria the book
is available at libraries and bookstores
everywhere there is even a discord where
you can discuss it while you read it
links in the doobly-doo below I look
forward to seeing many of you tonight in
New York for the launch and then on the
rest of the tour Hank you did it I will
see you on Friday
and also in a couple of hours